[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry's awful cousin
more specifically however we're going to
be discussing a false reality
in which dudley a muggle is magical
being shipped off to hogwarts alongside
harry in the year 1991
expanding on that we're going to discuss
what house
if any dudley would be sorted into would
he be
an ambitious slytherin a brave
gryffindor
a hard-working hufflepuff or a clever
ravenclaw
let's dive into it first let's look at
dudley as a person
dudley dursley was born the 23rd of june
two parents vernon dursley and petunia
evans
as a young boy he was about as awful as
you can be he tormented harry
bullied other children and was about as
spoiled and petulant as you can get
his insolence and general demeanor was
the result of his parents
spoiling him for his entire childhood
effectively producing
a demanding manipulative selfish
and ungrateful monster in addition to
his manipulative nature
dudley also had an affinity for bullying
weaker
younger children the mark of a true
coward this bullying even included harry
from time to
time though much more often in his
younger years
when harry had not yet fully honed his
magical abilities
dudley didn't really have many positive
qualities and it probably didn't help
that he had a relatively low level of
intelligence apparently
in addition to bullying students dudley
was actually dismissed from smelting's
academy
for poor academic performance so in
short
butler was a manipulative spoiled
petulant
selfish ungrateful and unintelligent
bully
my next question is where does that
leave him in terms of a hogwarts house
here's the thing it'd be unfair to
assign dudley to a house
based on his childhood alone because
believe it or not
as he grew older he turned into a
respectable young man
even creating some semblance of a
relationship with harry
the crossroads for dudley was the
dementor attack that occurred
in the order of the phoenix though the
dementors weren't able to successfully
suck out dudley's soul
the attack still had a profound impact
on him as it forced him to observe the
type of person that he was
not only that but harry saved his life
and for this he was eternally grateful
harry just didn't realize that until
much later this
is reinforced by jk rowling in an
interview people usually ask me
what is it that dudley saw during the
dementor attack rowling said
my feeling is that he saw himself
exactly for what he was and for a boy
that spoiled
it would be terrifying so he was jolted
out of it dementor attacks aren't
usually good for people
but this one was what this confirms is
that dudley changed
he really grew out of being the petulant
little boy that he once was
and it's even revealed that dudley later
felt remorse for the way that he treated
harry
as a boy dudley's tragedy was the
unfortunate conditions in which he was
raised
you see he never really stood a chance
with parents like vernon and petunia
who spoiled and infantilized him
dumbledore put it best himself
when discussing harry the best that can
be said is that he has at least
escaped the appalling damage you have
inflicted upon the unfortunate boy
sitting between you
given that dudley showed his true colors
later in life we're going to assume that
the sorting hat
would pick up on these less obvious
nascent qualities
similar to the way the sorting hat
picked up on neville's bravery
which wasn't necessarily apparent at the
time of sorting the sorting ceremony is
an annual tradition
at hogwarts it occurs at the beginning
of the school year and its function is
to assign
new students to one of the four houses
gryffindor hufflepuff
ravenclaw or slytherin students are
sorted using the sorting hat
a sentient hat that once belonged to
hogwarts founder godric
gryffindor recognizing that they each
valued very different
traits in students hence the rationale
for having four houses in the first
place
each founder passed on the main criteria
for their particular house to the hat
the student then places the hat on their
head and is assigned to a house
based on which founder they resemble
most
first things first i certainly don't
think the dudley was a ravenclaw
generally speaking
the defining characteristics of
ravenclaw house in a nutshell
are knowledge wisdom and a studious
nature
they are often but not always
exceptional students with a thirst for
knowledge
and unparalleled study habits raving
claws are like sponges
who take in their environments and
question well everything
all aspects of life exist to be
uncovered and examined
does this sound like dudley dursley to
you though he ended up being quite a
respectable
young man it doesn't mean that he was
especially inquisitive or
intelligent i mean he even flunked out
of smelting's academy
i think of all four houses dudley meshes
least well
with ravenclaw next up slytherin first
of all
let me just say that slytherins get a
bit of a bad rap
they are often unfairly and
automatically labeled as inherently
bad witches and wizards but this isn't
true
despite what you may believe being a
slytherin does not mean that you're evil
and i think that a lot of their bad
reputation comes from founder salazar
saliren's attitude towards blood purity
on the positive side slytherins are
often very clever
very resourceful very determined and
make great leaders
when you think of dudley dursley you
don't exactly think clever
resourceful determined or great leader
the only way that dudley fits in with
slytherin
is if you consider the false
generalization that slytherin is just
comprised of the bad eggs
but that's not true and dudley ends up
being a pretty respectable person
one of the biggest considerations here
is ambition
was dudley ambitious not really selfish
maybe
and was he a good leader certainly not
despite having a gang of cronies
he didn't really lead them slytherin in
my eyes
is the second least likely option for
deadly next
hufflepuff the defining characteristics
of a hufflepuff
are that they are hardworking wholesome
trustworthy and
loyal hufflepuff often gets a bit of a
hard time and is sometimes criticized
for being neither particularly
exceptional
or clever but this is far from the truth
as hufflepuff has produced
some of the most impressive witches and
wizards to date
witches and wizards like nymphadora
tonks cedric diggory
and even newt scamander were all
hufflepuffs and they were all
incredibly impressive so where does
dudley fit into all of this
the first qualities that i want to look
at are trust and loyalty
as a child and even as a young man
dudley had a group of friends that
followed him around
at first glance this could be perceived
as loyalty
to his friend group on dudley's part but
i think that
in reality it was more just convenient
for dudley
he wanted people to hang around with was
he particularly
loyal to them would he risk his life for
theirs i don't think so
the next aspect of being a hufflepuff
that i want to look at is their
hard-working nature
was dudley a hard worker well in a weird
sort of way
he was not at school and certainly not
at academics but in boxing in fact it's
revealed in the series that dudley at
one point
became the junior heavyweight
inter-school boxing champion
what this tells me is that if dudley
really put his mind to something
he could achieve it and does becoming a
boxing champion take a lot of hard work
definitely could dudley have been sorted
into hufflepuff
possibly last but not least we have
gryffindor house
the classic defining character trait of
gryffindor is bravery
something that is exhibited by the trio
time and time again
throughout the series gryffindors are
brave courageous
fearless and every other descriptor that
fits that category
bravery for gryffindors is valued above
all other traits
and we certainly know that if harry
hadn't been brave then the wizarding
world would have turned out a lot
differently
so is dudley dursley brave well
he actually kind of is you see when the
deathly hallows rolled around
and it's time for the dursleys to leave
harry dudley finally speaks up and acts
against his parents
by expressing genuine concern for
harry's safety he had been raised by his
parents to basically treat harry badly
and by worrying about him so openly he
was kind of acting in direct opposition
to his parents
this undoubtedly took a lot of bravery
and while we don't see dudley exhibit
this kind of bravery in any other
circumstance
this is one of the last things that we
see his character do leaving a
lasting impression when we think of
gryffindors we often think of brave
righteous and good sort of similar to
the way that we think of slytherins as
bad eggs
but just like with slytherin this
perception of the house
is basically just a false generalization
in fact there's one gryffindor student
that shares a lot in common with dudley
cormac mclagan like dudley mclagan was
arrogant
pompous entitled and even sometimes
aggressive
qualities which are almost contradictory
to the stereotypical
gryffindor-like qualities but mclagan
still made it into gryffindor
this is because all of those qualities
aside he was still brave
just in the foolhardy sense and not the
selfless sense
mclagan like dudley even had a bad
temper
as harry once thought mclagan was going
to punch him for not offering him
another quidditch tryout
in the end however it appeared that
mclagan was undergoing
growing pains in his youth just like
dudley as he ended up being quite a
brave
and righteous young man given dudley's
similarities to mclagan
i think the dudley would have most
likely been sorted into gryffindor house
a real surprise for his cousin harry i'm
sure
and that's it for this video what house
would you
place dudley in let me know in the
comment section below
until next time your wizard harry